have you added tasha to the group text
well no i mean i don't know her number
but i don't think anybody can get a hold
of her right now well that's because
tasia is our new bachelorette i'm ready
for my next
fun adventure multiple sources confirm
the news to et
on monday 29 year old tasia from colton
underwood season of the bachelor
has replaced claire crawley the most
recent bachelorette after just two weeks
of filming
why because claire has fallen for one of
her contestants
i want somebody that when things get
tough will not run away
now bachelor nation is weighing in on
the big shakeup
et spoke with past bachelorettes ali
fedotowsky and rachel lindsey
about tasia's new adventure i feel like
claire maybe
she was like there is no tattoo there's
a top one and i know it right now and
i'm done and i think that is so awesome
not only that she
figured that out if that's the case but
i think it's awesome of the show
to let that happen so the fact that
they're like shaking it up and like
saying sure fine you can go and we're
gonna bring in someone new i just think
that's so much fun
i think that my advice to her would be
different than anybody else and that's
because i think there's gonna be a lot
of focus
on her season of whether or not the guys
are there for her they all thought it
was gonna be claire and they knew it for
a while because of quarantine it's not
like it was
a surprise the bachelorette was and i
think
my advice to her would be just to let
that go don't focus on that because at
the end of the day it doesn't matter who
they showed up for
it matters how they feel in the end you
know like you're feeling you never know
how your feelings are going to be
um so i would just tell her not to focus
on that and let that go
as for rachel the first ever black
bachelorette
and until now the only one she tells et
she's thrilled about tasia's casting
after her calls for more diversity in
the franchise what i'm doing
is for people who look like me for other
for people of different backgrounds
ethnicities i feel like i'm fighting
this fight for them
and their place on the show rachel tells
e.t
quote i have been fighting for inclusion
and i've said before that tasia would be
an excellent bachelorette
so i am more than happy to pass the
torch i am so excited to see what she's
going to do
how she will represent herself and her
journey to find love
now she's in the driver's seat and i'm
excited to see her get this opportunity
i do feel like i'm making a difference
by using my voice
and not backing down from what i believe
in what i think is right
and where i think the franchise should
go the season is still full of mystery
what will we see of claire's journey is
she engaged and will
tasia find love the bachelorette
premieres this fall on abc